we need to be patient and there is no
shortcut we want to get everything done
tomorrow right so so sometimes there are
different priorities and different
realities in life as we see
pandemic now so you know it's it's a
marathon not a sprint it's a long
journey and and we need to be more
patient
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring upward slabs and hillel at
stanford speech to text has completely
transformed the way we handle data
meet tom livne the ceo and founder of
verbit the world's leading ai-powered
transcription and captioning platform
tom has vast leadership experience in
technology companies ranging from early
stage startups to enterprises with tens
of millions of dollars in annual revenue
tom served as a board member and
investor in convex zoom
a counter drone platform that was
acquired for 60 million dollars
he holds an llb nba from idc artsilia
and an
mba from the technion israel institute
of technology
thank you for joining me how are you i'm
good how are you michael
i'm doing fine thank you for joining me
are you in israel right now
yes i'm at my home in herzegovina yes
i love it so you know you're home by day
but but today you're also the ceo of
virbid ai
a fascinating company in the ai space
and the transcription space and i can't
wait to hear
all about this industry and the human
computer interaction when it comes to
you know speech to text and and how you
know the world was moving and what verb
ai is doing in that regard but i think
that even even before that i think your
journey is just
is just fascinating from being you know
a warrior and paramedic at the
paratroopers special forces
to getting your mba at yale school of
management
and all the way leading up to you know
being on the you know more in the
investment world in the dark world
and before becoming the ceo of verbit so
tom take me all the way back even if you
know you're apparent
to the paratrooper days do you know that
you're going to be
you know in the tech scene do you know
that you're going to become
an investor and a founder and a ceo was
that in you from a young age
you know i was always uh was a really
ambitious
guy that you know aiming to reach to the
top
as since i remember myself and you know
i remember that we had a debate
among of our friends that you know to
our parents
they had much you know more
opportunities to become successful in
their careers
because it was more blue ocean back then
for everything for real estates for
you know all different categories
and then i was like telling them i
disagree i think you know we are
you know born to the uh
decades of technology and high tech and
i think
uh we have you know endless
opportunities we just need to
to and for that even though if we are
not with the
you know technological background and
the 800 units etc
so i think i demonstrated that you don't
have to be
this kind of uh people
in order to be a successful career in
the tech scene so definitely
wanted to go into the tech world and to
prove uh
and to build something right and so so
you know that you want to build
something but you choose to
you choose to start your journey more on
the investment side on the financial
side and then
you know you see your associated lumita
you're also an investor with
some other groups and a private investor
and you know on the board member of
a drone company right which was acquired
by nso so
what was the transition towards the
investment world why not go straight
into you know being an entrepreneur
and and you know making it big
yes i think you know if uh we start
earlier
with the army as you discuss i think it
really helped me with resiliency right
so once you are in a special forces
it helps you uh in the future in your
career i didn't know how much it's gonna
help me
and then i said in order to be
successful entrepreneur in my point of
view
i need to to to learn it from from the
other side to see how
investors thinks how they're looking at
different companies how they evaluate so
i think it's really helped me
you know to get my perspective on on you
know
do's and don't do's and all the the
mistakes although
you know i did many mistakes
invertebrates although i think i thought
uh
you know i learned a lot from from
the investing side but then you know
once you go into it hands-on you always
uh do mistakes it's it's unavoidable
right at least for the first timers and
so yeah so
this was my strategy to to learn the the
profession from the inside and to get
the investor view
and then once you are you know going to
the entrepreneurial awards i think it's
really really
helped me you know with many skills like
fundraising
etc and um you know i feel lucky that i
implemented it successfully
amazing so talk to me a little bit about
the space that you chose to go into
and you know transcriptions you know
human computer interaction when
it comes to to speech to text different
use cases you know
all around the world and and even before
we talk about verb but i'd love to to
understand how you get there
right because it's it it doesn't sound
like this is you know
a problem that necessarily you know
dealt with yourself you know throughout
the years as you're you know in the
paratroopers or in the investment
perhaps it was i'm very curious
especially how do you get to you know
have the domain expertise knowing okay
this is a place
where i want to invest my time and
energy as an investor
you know that you always looked at the
founders experience and whether it was
relevant and whether they have product
market fit
so tell me a little bit about some of
your thought process as you're
as you're creating this company that is
soon to become you know an amazing
company here in israel
yes actually i was a frustrated customer
so you know my if i go back in my career
i'm a lawyer no one is perfect
right so our audience will forgive me
for that but
you know i remember as a lawyer you know
how much time and how much money we were
investing in
the legal transcription right then once
we got the trump
was always late not accurate and
sometimes i had to do the editing job
myself
and i was really really frustrated
customers and entrepreneur you're
looking for problem
with high friction low efficiencies
where you can bring the technology
and and then to change it around and
then when i started to investigate the
you know the transcription industry i
saw that the legal
transcription legal vertical is only one
use case
out of you know tens of use cases and
creating
a huge opportunity of 30 billion dollar
addressable market that
being said fully manual and really
legacy
market and i said hey you know it's a
great timing
great opportunity and then let's build
the
you know the awards uh ai based leading
company in the space here we are four
years
after uh we verb
well for four years after and and now
you're sort of you know a market leader
in this regard did you expect to reach
you know the milestone of raising from
you know
top top vcs like viola and going on to
raising a serious ca
i believe over 120 million dollars in
funding but but
did you really you know expect to reach
you know
these heights so soon so quickly
um the simple answer is no i can tell
you that i
i in a hooked i really hope to be there
and and
and i said you know i'm going to do my
very best
uh to to be where we are today and we
still you know at the beginning of the
journey in my point of view
you know i think that uh if i'm looking
what i'm expecting to be in four years
from now it's uh
you know uh um you know hundreds of
millions of dollars in revenue and
and billions of dollars in market cap
and publicly traded companies this is my
my vision for the next four years but
you know i i didn't anticipate it will
happen so
so fast i hope it will and i'm really
glad and happy that
you know it all came up together you
know from you know raising the right
investors making the right decision on
which vertical we should attack
earlier you know by the critical hire
right and the people you work
with because eventually it's all about
the people so a lot of
you know really really important
decisions we made along the journey that
brought us
to where we are today so
you're talking you know you mentioned
both was that you have over
400 years of your growth you know people
are
loving the product you're already
showing how you know it's relevant for
for tens of use cases but
i'd love to go a little bit higher and
and understand
you know a little bit better this this
market and and
how people are interacting with
computers because one of the things that
automatically i think of when i think of
speech to text and transcriptions
and i'm you know a you i'm one
particular use case for example for the
show where i have transcriptions
and it sounds like this is one of those
fields where
you really have to be really precise
right sometimes it is good enough to
have like 90 95
accuracy but especially when you're
going to medical and legal
you can't really afford to mess up a
word
right i mean that could literally be the
difference between going on record
uh truthfully or not truthfully so how
do you even
you know tackle because you said when
you started your one of the first use
cases was
coming from the financials and legal
scene and seeing how difficult it was
so how do you adjust on one hand you
have you know a startup
where you're gonna have bugs you know no
matter what on the other hand you're
choosing use cases that are that
inherently are some of the most
sensitive ones
yeah it's it's a great questions right
so um
you know we we started the earlier in
our career in
in the past in and of our bit in
the education space right and and then i
remember
you know and this isn't advices i'm
giving to all entrepreneurs right
so uh you know kind of fake it until you
make it right because you know once you
start
yeah building something you know you
cannot expect to be
full-blown ready and i remember when to
do our first customer i came and
you know told him we have an amazing
product
everything is you know ai based and
all the superlative you know you can
think on and then say hey
you know we want to work with you let's
do it and then i was like oh now
what we
gonna do we need to actually deliver to
the customer and then
we started doing it manually right i
remember every ceo
has like this uh you know moment of uh
you know the lowest moment in in in the
journey and
you know for me was like okay we were
managed to sell
the product to the first customer and
then we said okay now we really need to
deliver so until the product will be
ready we
i need to do it you know fully manual
myself and then so we started to to
develop and progress
as a company and how we are you know
ensuring and if you want to
dive into you know how we are ensuring
the top quality
with the human and the loop kind of uh
model
i think we'll need another 20 minutes to
discuss it because it's so complex from
you know how we have 22 000 freelancers
in our community so how we
recruit those 22 000 people then how we
train and onboard them
you know to work uh in on our platform
then how we build the
you know uh the credit score and do the
quality assessment make sure they're
reaching to the
100 accuracy etc so it's really really
complex and a lot of ip
and you need to think about it as uber
for transcription
right and i think one of the most i
think fascinating things to an outsider
looking at this journey is you made a
very deliberate decision
um on how you approach the market right
so you have companies like
auto ai you have the script that are
really trying to you know give the
layman you know
every person you know who needs these
tools you know some something that
something that works
with a relatively good accuracy but but
you came and you said you know
i'm not really interested right now and
you know
giving everybody this this access and
being 100 for everybody but you're going
to tackle these
specific industries that need really
tailored solutions
like medical like finance like legal
which you know
on their own there are tens of billions
of dollars in market
what was the decision process for you
like did you
intend to go that route did you
understand that you need to focus in
order to succeed or
or maybe you now in retrospect if you
say you know what maybe we could have
gone to all
to everything we didn't need to
necessarily just focus on that
yes i think you know it started with
like the
you know the dna right so i think uh the
dna and what is more suitable is b2b
company rather than b2c what you the
names you described there are more b2c
related companies
and i remember i had a friend of mine um
where a ceo of uh you know similar
translation company
told me look to my companies i have
you know a x amount of uh let's call it
20 million dollars in revenue and i have
more than 100 000 customers
right and then he said my competitor
they have uh 500 million
in revenue think guess how many
customers they have
and he told me 700 right so i said wow
okay so it means you need to and
eventually if you look at
all the public credit companies etc they
are making most of the revenue from the
fortune 500
fortune 1000 fortune 2000 companies
right so
you know then i said we need to be a b2b
company and look for the bigger
customers and to serve them well and
make sure they're happy and growing with
us over time and one of the
you know you mentioned that we grow more
than 400
last year which is was an amazing year
but also
really important and critical figure
is what we call the net dollar retention
we're making sure that our customer
happy
and growing with us over time and so we
able to to get more
uh you know feature for them and more
usage for them so
everyone is happy so this is a critical
focus for us
in the company and you know once you're
doing it more b2c
you barely know your customer it's
really hard at least the way we build
our company to bring value so
you know that the market is big enough
to have two kinds of
uh approach and companies but we are
definitely more suitable for the
you know the b2b and the enterprise so
as as the as
you know a leader in this in this
company you're seeing this growth
obviously your role is changing on a
day-to-day basis right
a company that i believe pretty much you
know aimed to double its size
during you know 2020 your your job
changes your focus changes and your
understanding of the market changes as
you're obviously managing
these these clients how do you
make sure your customers are happy how
because you know a technology first
company
that you know you need technology proper
technology
where the human in the loop and this
whole system of onboarding these 20 000
people are helping at the end really
what it comes down to is whether
this the the main customers are happy so
how do you actually go about that sales
cycle
and and get that quick feedback to make
sure you really
retain them yes i think
it's it's easy you can describe it in in
two words
it's communication and people right so
eventually
you know we we hire the best people we
have the
you know amazing customer success team
and the leader of the customer success
team are
doing phenomenal jobs right and they're
all
about serving the customer and listening
to the customers and setting the right
processes
and the right communication tools you
know in order to listen to them and to
be responsive if they have any problems
or you know we said hey let's let's
let's uh
think together let's um bring together
which kind of features you would like to
see and then we are prioritizing it in
our roadmap
and investing in the r d to stay
competitive and and to lead
the market and to innovate the market so
again it's all about having the right
people in place and then you know having
good uh and transparent communication
and
you know sometimes i what what i learned
is all about setting the right
expectation right so you can
say hey you know y a x y z
and then the customer is getting
something different then
you know there is a disappointment and
then it's all
um you know starting to go to the wrong
path so definitely we work a lot about
the communication and setting the right
expectation
and since then everyone is really really
happy i love that and and talk
a little bit about the innovation
approach and in a really b2b company
with
with these sorts of clients how do you
actually go about it doing discovery
really understanding okay these are
perhaps the new verticals that we want
to tackle
or these are shortfalls or shortcomings
in this vertical that we want to tackle
and
and sort of how do you even think about
your thought you're outlining this
vision
four years from now how do you grow back
think okay what is the world going to
look like
for transcriptions specifically in those
sectors in four years because
you know nobody knows but as you know
the visionary of the company you kind of
have to
pick the way over there yeah but i think
it's a two different questions one is
like our strategy which verticals
we gonna attack later and then how we
innovate i think it's two different uh
questions so i'll answer both so i think
in terms of strategy we're looking
and on we set like three categories and
then we we
we rank them and then just how we get
the decision first is
is how big is the vertical
second is like how competitive is the
vertical
you know who is our competitor and third
how much
uh r d investment we need to do in order
to penetrate right and then you kind of
answer all those uh um questions and
then
according to that you set the strategy
okay because there is minimal investment
in r d this is so big
vertical although there is a lot of
competitors we think we can win because
of one two three right so
this is how we think about the strategy
and how we had another verticals
in terms of innovation right so which is
much more difficult
in my point of view so then we need to
come up with some thesis
right around what we want to build and i
can give an example so we are
you know a major player in the legal
transcription vertical
so you know one one part of our plan
to this year isn't to be beyond
transcription is not just to give the
the transcription of the depositions is
to give insights to the lawyer and what
do i mean by that
right so think about that you are
transcribing a deposition or
and you have the the witness that all
also
gave his um the deposition
you know two weeks ago and now in the in
this the position he is contradicting
himself
right because we transcribed both the
previous one and this one
we can see that the inconsistency and
then to give
a push notification and insight in real
time to the lawyer
to make sure that he is identifying that
right so uh
this is kind of uh a teaser that we
build that we think it's going to bring
value
to our customers and then you know we
kind of need to
to be able to tell the story in the
right way
and then to start do some market
validation and see if the customer will
be willing to pay
for this and also to hear from them
let's dream together what we'd like to
see uh
in this product and then kind of writing
down the ideas
and thinking about it internally and see
it if it makes sense and this is how we
make sure we are ahead of the curve in
terms of innovation and leading
the the market i love it tom a
fascinating journey
uh i think that you're i i think that
you know
a few things that i took particular
inspiration from i think one of them is
is another idea of focus this idea of
setting expectations but
but being very intentional with what the
company is trying to achieve and not
stopping there but thinking okay how can
we
how can we build upon that and look at
the world you know in a bigger sphere
with what you're doing now and what you
just mentioned that i think is
is just brilliant and i have two uh
short but difficult questions to ask you
one is
what is one thing that you would tell
yourself back
when you were you know paramedic and
paratroopers what what would you tell
you know young tom as he's preparing to
go on this journey this is particularly
directed to
you know the young entrepreneurs and
engineers following this
that it's a very very long journey
and you know although we entrepreneurs
this is not the strongest
characteristic which is patience right
so we need to be patient
and there is no shortcut although you
want to get everything done
tomorrow right so so sometimes there are
different priorities and different
realities in life as we see with the
covet pandemic now
so you know it's it's a marathon not a
sprint it's a long journey and and we
need to be more patient
i love it yes i think sometimes we
forget that you know in 20 minutes we
cover you know
years of journeys and insights you know
verbit over four years in the making
it's it's
so young to reach the milestones that
you've reached but still
four years is a long time uh to and in
20 minutes sometimes it feels short so
thank you for mentioning that and the
most important question
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
um passionate resilient entrepreneur
i love it thank you very very much
i love the journey that you're on and i
and i'm getting inspired by
and not just talking to you but by
following from the sidelines so thank
you for making the time to speak with me
today
and stay safe and stay healthy thank you
mike and thanks for hosting me it was a
pleasure
[Music]